We are all looking for a reason to feel good.
Something so simple, yet somehow made into
something so complicated.
We often have this tendency to think that
we need a reason to feel good about being
alive.
That we need to do things, own things, and
achieve things.
And perhaps that is the problem.
Of course it is important that we participate
in external activities because it stimulates
our experience of life, engages us in the
give and take, and pragmatically speaking,
it is required to establish financial stability
and general safety.
But the things that we do and acquire should
not be the sole factors by which we derive
feeling good about life.
The material world is in flux.
Cycles rotate in ways that are often arbitrary
and out of anyone’s control.
What was new and cool last year is likely
not this year.
And things that we once thought would make
us feel good forever, like a nice house, a
cool car, a career promotion, etc. ultimately
at some point fade into the background of
our lives and no longer make us feel the same
level of joy and appreciation compared to
when we first acquired them.
And so, these kinds of reasons to feel good
just become reasons to look for more reasons
to feel good, pushing us further and further
away from ever being able to just simply feel
good.
When we depend our ability to feel good on
things outside of our self, we over complicate
something that is inherently simple.
The reason to feel good needs no reason beyond
itself.
If your goal is to feel good, then you already
have the only reason you need.
You have the spirit of life and positivity.
You believe that life is so incredible that
there should be no moment where you do not
feel intoxicated by its bliss.
So if you are not already, feel good right
now.